Olha só, você sabia que aquele
iboprofeno que você tem aí na gaveta
pode literalmente fazer sua pele se
soltar do corpo? Pois é, parece filme de
terror, mas aconteceu de verdade. Uma
americana tomou buprofeno duas vezes ao
dia para dor pós-parto, coisa normal,
né? Só que desenvolveu uma reação
raríssima chamada síndrome de Steven
Johnson. A pele dela 95%
simplesmente se soltou do corpo, foi
parar na UT de queimados como induzido
3% de chance de sobreviver. E hora que
ela só tomou a dose normal, nada de
exagero. Isso acontece quando o sistema
imune pirou completamente com remédio.
Começa a aparecer numa gripe, febre,
malestar, olho irritado. Aí aparecem
esbolhas na pele, manchas vermelhas, a
boca fica cheia de feridas. Se você
notar qualquer manchinha estranha depois
de tomar inflamatório, para tudo vai pro
hospital. Não é para esperar, não é para
ver se melhora. Então fica alerta.
Iboprofeno não é balinha. Da próxima vez
que for tomar, presta atenção no seu
corpo nas primeiras 72 horas. Yeah.